Trascrizione: Stefania Recchia
Revisore: Laura Pasquale
[Sottofondo musicale: Macklemore & Ryan Lewis,
Can't Hold Us, con Ray Dalton]
[Applausi]
Io avevo scelto quelle immagini
perché erano vispe, e anche la musica.
Perché raccontavano delle cose
che ogni tanto noi,
soprattutto noi donne,
non osiamo fare.
"Done is better than perfect"
nel senso che noi spesso
siamo portate a fare le cose così bene,
così bene, che intanto qualcun'altro
tira via, le fa e prende il potere.
Per essere onesta...
[Applausi]
non volevo fare un discorso femminista,
io non lo sono.
Però mi è capitato di costruire
tutta la vita aziende.
Le immagini che vanno adesso delle frasi
me le sono trascritte nei quaderni.
Non è tutto digitale!
Ci sono stati quaderni per anni
di frasi che mi davano fiducia.
Questo è un progetto non-profit
che si chiama Web Of Life,
e che unisce le nostre aziende.
Non-profit cioè,
il criterio che ci diamo è che
"insieme reinvestiamo tutto",
ci diamo tutti uno stipendio, compresa me,
che è molto simile a quello di tanti dirigenti,
e il resto serve per fare posti di lavoro
e per costruire progetti.
Perché questa è la mia responsabilità adesso,
è la nostra responsabilità adesso.
In un'Italia in cui ci sarà sempre meno lavoro
e probabilmente il denaro si
concentrerà progressivamente,
come in tutto il capitalismo occidentale,
nelle mani di alcune persone,
un po' sempre meno.
Non sto facendo un discorso demagogico.
Le frasi che scorrono lo so
che non c'entrano niente
e distraggono, però Peter Pan ci stava
in mezzo a tutto il resto.
E le abbiamo montate in casa,
come il video di prima,
è montato in casa... vuol dire
montato fra di noi,
non è niente di così lontano o celebrativo.
Ho 55 anni,
ho fondato la prima azienda a 23,
che stavo ancora finendo
gli esami in università.
E l'ho fondata perché non mi
hanno preso come giornalista
e io sognavo di fare ricerca o di fare ---
è la verità, io sono andata al Gazzettino,
studiavo a Venezia.
Quando ho capito che, insomma,
non funzionavano i miei sogni,
mi sono detta, "Mi devo
riorganizzare velocemente.
Io non resterò anni a sperare di trovare
un reddito adeguato in università.
Io non ho pazienza di fare la
porta-borse di un professore."
E quindi ho corretto i sogni.
E la ragione per cui abbiamo, ho
– stavolta l'ho scelto io, questo titolo –
è un film che uscirà a Natale
di Ben Stiller,
che racconta la storia di un uomo,
ma potrebbe essere molto
anche per le donne,
che prima sogna, sogna
una vita che lui non è,
e lavora nella redazione di Life.
Il trailer è sulla rete, se ve lo
guardate è carino, credo.
E poi a un certo punto entra nel suo sogno,
e cambia la sua vita.
Allora, per quanto mi riguarda,
sono entrata nel sogno presto,
ma non perché avevo le idee chiare.
Come direbbe Steve Jobs,
"Solo unendo i puntini dopo,
ho capito il valore delle sconfitte".
Mi ricollego alle meravigliose
parole di Barbara Stefanelli.
Perché io la mia fragilità non
la sapevo affatto abbracciare,
e siccome non sapevo abbracciare la mia,
non sapevo neanche
abbracciare quella degli altri.
E quando non ero felice, morsicavo.
Morsico ancora, però chiedo scusa.
Questo è il miglioramento, ecco, è l'unico
miglioramento che ho imparato.
Devo dire, l'ho imparato man
mano che ho avuto meno paura.
Ecco. Perché se siamo
feroci con noi stesse
– parlo al femminile, prevalentemente –
o con noi stessi,
è perché abbiamo paura,
e io che amo tanto gli animali,
imparo che i miei cani ringhiano
– non tutti, qualcuno –
quando hanno paura di una situazione,
o quando hanno sofferto prima, o altro.
E lo stesso fanno i miei figli adolescenti,
ci ringhiamo ogni tanto, ma
ho imparato ad abbracciare
quando mi verrebbe da contrappormi.
E per quanto riguarda il lavoro,
ho imparato nel tempo
una modalità diversa.
Sono partita facendo
totalmente la padroncina
della mia prima azienda.
Ho fatto vestiti, moda, per tanti anni,
prevalentemente questo, quasi solo questo,
dai 23 anni ai 43 anni.
E mi piaceva tanto comandare io,
mi piaceva tanto guidare.
È un lavoro bello fare
le collezioni dei vestiti,
è un lavoro... è come
lavorare sui colori,
è come lavorare sui
materiali, sulle forme.
E io sono stata rintanata in
questo ruolo per tanti anni,
continuavo a sognare di fare tanti figli,
era il mio primo sogno,
non ho mai smesso.
Vengo da una famiglia di cinque figli.
Però non mi venivano,
e quando li aspettavo,
li perdevo anche,
per cui in realtà ne ho fatti quattro,
ne ho persi sei in gravidanza
e una in affido,
l'unica femmina è arrivata in affido.
Che è una meraviglia ovviamente.
È una meraviglia l'affido...
[Applausi]
No, scusate, ma… [Sospiro]
No, è una meraviglia l'affido
perché è un'altra maternità, come dire,
in cui ti nasce di colpo una vita davanti,
ed è sua, non ti appartiene,
non l'hai generata dalla tua pancia,
non hai neanche avuto
il tempo di pensarci tanto.
Ed è una meraviglia la storia di Zineb,
che ora è sposata, vive in Inghilterra,
ed è partita da una storia
di immenso dolore
di violenza, eccetera.
Ed è una donna libera,
e grande, e bella.
E quindi, si.
[Applausi]
E poi gli altri figli hanno
dai 14 ai 21 anni,
e sono tutti maschi,
e io intanto continuo, come dire,
a vivere come figli...
scusate, ma insomma ogni
persona che lavora con me,
anche se sono più grandi di me,
fra i figli e i fratelli, non so, è una
cosa terribilmente biologica per me
terribilmente di amore,
e poi magari ricomincerò con altri bambini
non più generati dalla pancia,
più avanti, quando avrò più tempo.
In questi anni ho imparato un modo
di lavorare nuovo, insieme ad altre donne.
Ci sono due donne che sono, come dire,
le mie due grandi socie, e
sono a capo dei due gruppi:
una sta sulla moda a Treviso,
un'altra sta a Milano.
E sono arrivate da me
giovanissime, cioè, voglio dire,
una neo-laureata
e l'altra si stava laureando, era in stage.
E siamo cresciute insieme,
tutta la vita voglio dire,
litigando anche molto eh,
cioè proprio, della serie..
"E tu fidati!", "No, fidati tu!"
Però, però bellissimo, una
lunga, lunga storia di
tanti, tanti anni.
Al di là di loro, gli altri sono
tutti maschi, gli altri soci.
Non è una scelta, accade perché?
Perché abbiamo, noi donne, meno
il coraggio di intraprendere,
a parità di competenza.
Riflettiamoci.
Perché? Perché ci stimiamo meno.
Ci stimiamo meno capaci
di fare i grandi capi,
e questo non c'entra col valore reale,
c'entra secondo me
col fatto di essere
la prima generazione
che prova a fare tutto,
tutto insieme.
E quindi per me, che
ho attraversato l'Africa,
perché è un continente
che mi piace tanto,
e ho visto donne con
uno sguardo magnifico
pestare manioca nei villaggi e
la differenza fra loro e
me non era l'intelligenza,
era il luogo in cui eravamo nate
e quello che c'era stato
dato di vivere come donne.
Io, io credo che siamo una
generazione di frontiera,
siamo una generazione pioniera.
Mi vengono in mente le donne del West,
sui carri, quelle che portavano i carri,
nelle scene del West, no?
Gli uomini erano a cavallo,
ma loro portavano i carri
con la famiglia, col carico,
con gli attrezzi dietro
per costruire una fattoria,
picchettare sul fiume, eccetera.
Allora io credo che
stiamo vivendo questo.
E credo però che sia un'avventura
meravigliosa nella fatica.
Nella fatica perché, a me è
accaduto di separarmi due volte,
cioè, mi hanno lasciata due volte.
Sintesi: non volevo io.
[Risate]
Io non volevo, io volevo
una famiglia per sempre.
Volevo tanti bambini, volevo
essere la mamma perfetta.
Però se non mi fosse successo
tutta questa cosa qui,
io non avrei imparato a lavorare così,
e non avrei usato il tempo
del dolore per costruire,
con più energie residue,
che dovevo convertire
in qualcosa di buono,
progetti nuovi.
Avrei fatto la cretina, avrei fatto
shopping, avrei avuto amanti
e storie così.
Morale: no tante sconfitte,
piccole o grandi,
davvero, al di là dell'immagine mitica
ho consegnato un libro un po' di mesi fa
e nello scrivere è stata una grande
autoterapia di riflessione,
di mettere insieme,
di accorgermi, che ogni volta,
si ripartiva da un errore o
si ripartiva da una sconfitta.
E si ripartiva più forti,
a partire dall'esserci accolti.
Scusa se mi ricollego ancora,
io tua utente notturna eh,
perché ti leggo di notte,
perché di giorno lavoro
e di notte dico "Premio! Si legge
e si guarda la puntata".
Per cui grazie! Ecco, perché
veramente mi fai bene!
Comunque a che punto siamo?
Siamo al punto che stiamo costruendo,
sì, aziende, progetti,
alcuni dei vostri colleghi lavorano con noi
e li conoscete anche, sapete chi sono.
Ed è una grande comunità,
di uomini e di donne,
con degli equilibri di potere interessanti
perché non funziona normalmente,
quando si impara a sorridere,
a ridere gli uni degli altri
e a non giocare il vecchio
gioco del "Comando io!"
È interessante ed è anche possibile.
È possibile, però io sono partita dal mollare
le dinastie familiari, c'era un unico
fratello che lavorava in Doxa,
a un certo punto gli ho detto "Fuori!
Scusa, no, ci sono due
donne più brave di te,
non della famiglia, io ho
una responsabilità verso tutti".
Voi direte "Ah che tosta!",
ma guardate che se i vostri genitori
non vi parlano per un po'
non è che sia propria
una roba panoramica,
per un po', a lungo, no?
E la vostra mamma,
così forte, così brava,
vi disapprova.
Io voglio dire, io sono una
che va in collisione,
però avevo tanto bisogno di essere approvata
anch'io da quelli che ho più amato.
Non passa sempre dall'approvazione,
passa però dalla dignità con cui
guardiamo indietro la
nostra storia e diciamo,
"Non mi vergogno di niente,
non voglio più vergognarmi
se per caso ho piegato la testa
[Applausi]
per inseguire un piacere
momentaneo o una gratificazione
o un successo momentaneo",
perché tanto non tiene.
Per cui a tutte voi vorrei solo dire:
Crediamoci!
E invece di sognare e basta,
stop dreaming,
ma non per accantonare i sogni,
per... per non mancare di rispetto
alla bambina che eravamo
o al bambino che eravamo, per gli uomini,
e che sognava una vita
e continuava a fidarsi.
Io non ho smesso di fidarmi.
Ogni tanto la prendo sui denti
ma non è grave, non mi
considero idiota per questo.
Penso che se non solo
non perdo di umanità
ma imparo a volermi bene,
errori compresi,
imparerò a volere più bene agli altri
e avrà un senso diverso tutto.
[Applausi]